[Música]
quiero contarles un par de anécdotas que
me sucedieron en las dos últimas semanas
la primera es necesite viajar a los
Estados Unidos y me comunique con mi
empresa telefonía celular para poder
tener acceso a roaming
después de visitar en muchas ocasiones
todo lo que las instrucciones me decían
por teléfono terminaba saliéndome un
mensaje que mi teléfono no podía ser
visto en esa plataforma porque
pertenecía a una plataforma corporativa
finalmente se corta la llamada y vuelvo
a acceder y trato de comunicarme por la
que es de persona natural y tampoco
logro obtener una respuesta finalmente
me toca viajar a los Estados Unidos y
telefonía y tratar de resolver con el
wi-fi que pudiera tener en los sitios
públicos
pero llego a Colombia y necesito acceder
a mi servicio de salud y me veo con una
sorpresa y es que nuevamente entro al
tema de una página donde muy bien
diseñada me dice por favor te las
opciones que están aquí establecidas de
preguntas escoja la que usted necesita
pero resulta que nada y lo que estaba
escrito corresponde a mi necesidad
afortunadamente existía la posibilidad
escribirla y he bueno vamos a escribirla
y a digitar la y la respuesta que me
daba automatizada era la manera que te
ha diseñado la pregunta no es válida por
favor reconsidere y reconfigure Supremo
lo realice en cuatro ocasiones y tampoco
fue posible
y ahí es cuando yo empiezo a pensar
será que esto le está pasando a los
usuarios de las instituciones en donde
he trabajado cuando hablamos de
digitalización digi turno call center
inteligencia artificial minería de datos
estructuración de una serie de cosas que
no te puedes gastar para darle en teoría
respecto a los usuarios pero que
claramente a mí me estaba pasando en
donde no me dan respuesta y empecé a
hacer memoria de lo que sucedía cuando a
uno le le pasa esto cuando a uno le
ofrecen un producto es y se da cuenta
que casi todos los indicadores están
basados en productividad en eficiencia
el número siguiente más económicos pero
a veces perdemos de foco que detrás de
todo esto y un ser humano
y mirando los indicadores con los que
vienen por ejemplo en eficiencia de un
Call Center y la eficiencia de un Call
Center esta medida porque el 85% de las
llamadas pueden ser contestar porque
inicialmente se respondían 3000 y ahora
se responden 6000 esas cosas hoy parecen
que son los que estábamos buscando pero
nos olvidamos nuevamente el celular
quién de ustedes no ha vivido una
situación particular en este aspecto y
le queda un sentimiento de frustración
otro de los puntos importantes es cuando
nosotros estamos construyendo las
planeación estratégica de las
organizaciones de salud sobre todo en la
prestación
tiempo hemos hablado de lo que es el
modelo de atención
y nos llenamos de orgullo diciendo que
el modelo de atención es el que está
centrado en el paciente y su familia
pero cuándo vamos a ver la realidad yo
diría que no es así y que no estamos
honrando lo que estamos cometiendo
tenemos serios inconvenientes
y podemos solucionar oportunidades
podemos solucionar acceso podemos
solucionar muchas deficiencias pero nos
olvidamos de muchas otras cosas que el
paciente requiere
para contarles un ejemplo
anecdótico
es que yo no sé indicador que es de
obligatorio cumplimiento que se llaman
las consultas en los servicios de
urgencias
y cuando analizamos ese indicador me
llevé una sorpresa y es que la gran
mayoría personas que eran re
consultantes definidos como tres o más
veces en un mes al servicio urgencias es
porque querían ir a relacionarse con
alguien a tener la posibilidad de
conversar con alguien
y cuando nosotros hablamos de
humanización es donde tenemos que entrar
a resolver esa situación pero si se lo
dejamos a una inteligencia artificial
pues claramente no va a respuesta de lo
que creas
dos significa que yo estoy diciendo que
no debemos entrar en esa era significa
que el planteamiento es donde está el
mecanismo de control válvula de escape
para que no nos olvidemos de ser humano
y ahí puedo contarles una anécdota que
es bastante interesante y es como
se instala en unos kioscos en la
organización para poder acceder a tener
esa consulta o apodera priorizar esa
consulta
y empezamos a notar que hay dos grupos
grandes poblacionales que quedan por
fuera el adulto mayor y aquella
población discapacidad y creemos que eso
va a ser una barrera y realmente no lo
fue
diseñamos la posibilidad de que alguien
acompañara
en los momentos en que voy a dificultad
para poder resolver con esa kiosco con
esa estación que permitía el
asentamiento
y vimos con sorpresa que la eficiencia
la eficacia y la productividad
creció casi en un 30%
es decir tenemos que romper esa barrera
en donde creemos que solamente lo que
está sistematizado lo que es eficiente
simplemente es adicionar la posibilidad
de encontrar ese ser humano que está
detrás
para nadie es un secreto que en pandemia
nos tuvimos que adaptar a la virtualidad
y esa virtualidad no es igual que
instituciones como las que yo dije en
ese momento saltar a Esther o consultas
a 11000 consultas en un mes con la
virtualidad
pero en qué momento nos vamos a
preocupar que realmente la solución a es
pacientes estuvieran
y tenemos que hacer el ejercicio y
empezamos a pintar como podíamos
nosotros crear no solamente encuesta de
satisfacción sino encuestas de cómo
podríamos medir que el paciente tuviera
una solución
el segundo concepto que me parecía
importante es que esto lo tenemos como
para ahorrar tiempo
ya sabemos que todo lo que nos han
vendido es para aumentar la eficiencia y
los costos mejorar el ingreso mejorar
los márgenes olvidándonos del ser humano
que está detrás
pero tiempo para que y es la segunda
reflexión
tiempo para poder utilizarlo en
construcción de esa personalidad tiempo
para poder disfrutar con la familia y
verdaderamente hablar de humanización
recordemos que el ser homínidos no es
igual un ser humano
en 0 minutos es producto de haber puesto
en dos patas
pero compartimos eso con los orangutanes
y con los chimpancés el ser humano es el
aprendizaje que tenemos en la
constitución como sociedad
y algo que siempre hemos hablado y que
aprendí con la pandemia es que no era
solamente hablar del distanciamiento
social era hablar de distanciamiento
porque como sociedad y te que teníamos
que acercar
y empezamos a ver
algunas estadísticas que quiero
mencionar
por ejemplo las el sentimiento de
soledad
el 30% de los hogares unipersonales se
sienten solos
a diferencia de cuando son de 3 o más
componentes en donde siente menos del
20% de esa soledad
entonces nosotros estamos migrando para
dar más tiempo para sentirnos solos
cómo podemos nosotros introducir dentro
de eso la capacidad de que esos mismos
sistemas de información sistemas de
robotizacion Sistema de Inteligencia
Artificial permiten al ser humano
utilizar ese tiempo libre para ser más
creativos y para poder diseñar cosas que
sean en bienestar de ese mismo ser
humano es un reto y es el reto que
quiero dejar plantear
porque finalmente tenemos que recurrir a
las bases de lo que nosotros construimos
sobre todo como médico en el tema en
donde
una de las raíces fundamentales
es el juramento hipocrático y en ese
juramento hipocrático y algo que es el
dictamo hipocrático y es primo no no ser
primero no hacer daño y la invitación es
a construir
desaprender lo aprendido y pensar en que
lo que estamos haciendo tiene que
repercutir en el bienestar del ser
humano
[Música]